Good afternoon everybody.
Hi. We're delighted to welcome you for this
last events in our series of professional developments.
For those who don't know me,
my name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the Yale Quantum institute and I'll be moderating this panel.
We are delighted to continue this series that is jointly organized by
the engineering workforce development of the Center for Quantum network in Arizona.
This is our last panel, the fifth one.
We'll focus today on job in the industry [inaudible].
We wanted to offer the series because there's a lot of question about
what classes should I take to
join the workforce and working quantum physics or quantum science.
Should I be more of a physicist,
more of engineer or more of a quantum scientist?
We recognize that there's a lot of people
needed from very different backgrounds to be able to
achieve all the technical details that we need to
have a robust quantum science for your information and build quantum systems.
It could be very overwhelming to consider
all these options for carrier in quantum information.
Today we will hear from
recent young professional who are graduated and
joined industry as well as carry different professional.
We'll be here to answer all of your question.
Before we start, I would like to introduce Matheus.
He's on council for the center of quantum network
and he might say a few words about the work that he does.
Hello everyone. Well, my name is Matheus.
It's a pleasure to be here with you today.
CQN is a research center funded by NSF with the goal to build a quantum network.
I currently work with the development of
algorithms to work on the software part of the quantum network.
Essentially, we have the working groups in many different aspects of the field from
really physical research to actually build the quantum [inaudible] than you actually need
for quantum network to the spectrum of
the impacts that quantum network would bring to society.
Thank you very much for this.
If you want to learn more about them,
visit the CQN website.
Let's jump right in and let's introduce our participants.
If you can put your channel on on your webcam.
While you do so, I would like to give you a little bit
of advice and design for the series.
We're going to start with the introduction of
the panelists and then all the attendees can use
the Q&A feature at the bottom of
your screen where you will see or you can ask all the questions.
You will go through during the hour,
we'll go through all of the questions and try to answer all of them.
Let's start by introducing our panelists.
Let's start with Teresa, for example.
Hi. We keep it to from your webcam and so go ahead.
Hello. I'm Teresa Brecht.
I'm a researcher doing quantum device physics at HRL laboratories in Malibu, California.
This isn't the real ocean,
it's just a backdrop on below.
But the real ocean is just right out there.
It's nice and warm today.
Here I work on quantum dot cubits doing experiments
and measurements and also developing software for those.
I've been doing that at HRL for almost five years.
My background before joining HRL was in superconducting cubits.
I graduated from Yale in 2017 and my PhD advisor was [inaudible] there. That's it.
Thank you very much. Zlatko, do you want to go next?
Sure. It'd be my pleasure. Hi everybody.
Tuning in, I'm actually in California right now too,
though normally based in New York City.
It's actually really great to be back at Yale at least virtually.
I overlap with Teresa,
I think she's looking at the same time.
I was in the Applied Physics Department with Michelle [inaudible] from 2018 to 2011.
After working very hard in the last few years of my PhD
to finish those last project I was doing catching university and quantum jump,
I think I applied something like
10 or 15 postdoc positions and basically everywhere in industry.
I wish we had these panels earlier and it's so awesome.
At the time was a different landscape.
I'm really thrilled that Florian and YQI and
the new institute here in central are organizing these
because this is exactly what I would've loved to have even more of.
Then I moved on to hear the story later.
I moved on to research path at IBM quantum computing.
I've since had a little more unorthodox path.
I've now found it and I'm the technical lead of
our quantum device design and analysis project called Qiskit metal,
which makes it possible for basically the first time for anyone to design
their own quantum devices from their computer and
really speed up and accelerate the process and the innovation.
I also lead and
host IBM Qiskit quantum information seminar series
and I'm a lecturer at the Global Summer School for Qiskit.
Recently, thankful to share that my roles
expanded to also found a new team that's going up to as high risk, high reward research.
That's in a management position as well,
while still staying very focused on the research aspects of it.
A bit unusual and a bit more hybrid in that sense.
Hopefully I will have a few interesting tips and to send messages to share.
Thank you very much Zlatko.
Then our last panelist Melanie if you wants to [inaudible] introduce yourself.
Thank you so much Florian.
My name is Melanie Sinche and I serve as
the Interim Assistant Dean for Academic Affairs and the
Director of the Career Center at the University of St. Joseph,
which is in the Center of Connecticut.
I'm actually in the Northeast right now.
Right now I'm also serving as a consultant to Yale University and I'm
working with all of their PhDs and postdocs with all disciplines,
primarily in the sciences.
But I have been a career counselor for just over 20 years now.
My specialization is working with PhDs and postdocs and the sciences.
I actually wrote a book on how to find a job for
PhDs in any branch of science called next-gen PhD.
If any of you are interested or want to connect,
please feel free to get in touch with me if you have questions following today's panel.
I love connecting with scientists at any level.
If they are undergraduates on the call or graduate students of postdocs.
I'm also happy to connect with Zlatko and Teresa and Florian and
Matheus because I love learning more about science.
I'm not a quantum scientists on the panel,
but I'm interested in hearing about the paths of Zlatko and Teresa.
Thank you for having me Florian.
Thank you. That's my pleasure.
Let's jump right in on the questions.
I think that's going to be the first question I have is,
what it's like to work in industry because people asking that question,
I've been at school for all this time.
You go to high school and college, grad school maybe.
What is it like? What's the difference?
Because all of you were in labs like students and so.
Who wants to start with this question,
what's the main difference?
What you should look for and all of that? Who wants to jump first?
I can maybe lead it off if you like then Teresa you can jump in.
I think maybe the first thing to just acknowledge is that it's not monolithic,
whether it's an academia or in industry.
I was thinking about this a little bit because the experience I
think I had starting at Yale in my graduate degree in 2010,
2011 is very different in a sense from experience as
students starting today would have the whole landscape of quantum has changed a lot.
I think maybe that's the caveat to begin with,
is that it's easy to plug the blanket statement of industry,
but really there's so many different flavors and that's part of what your experiences.
It feels like a bigger world in some sense.
It's a lot more dynamic.
Part of what you'll definitely see in a lot of industry,
especially as you move into more technology industry.
The industry that quantum is headed into is that it's a little closer
to the machine learning tech industry where
things happen in two-year cycles, three years cycles.
The pace is definitely
one major change that you have in terms of certain schedules and pace.
Also you will work in much larger groups and teams.
Typically, it's definitely more oriented.
They are potentially creating stuff.
It's a little less significance driven than published this paper or so forth.
I think at the same time though,
really depends because there are many different cultures.
You had a startup panel,
it's going to have a different slant on it versus a large organization like IBM,
which is huge and it's very global and worldwide.
You're going to work with people that come from tons of different backgrounds.
This is one of the maybe biggest differences.
Now, I'm not constantly surrounded by
like-minded people who had the exact same training for the last 20 years as me.
In physics, I'm working with software developers,
product designers, physicists, engineers,
material scientists who have different trainings.
Whose value system is a bit different than mine.
We're not all after the same thing.
I think readjusting my own values in this environment,
it is one thing that I think inadvertently will happen.
That's also true and active too.
I think as you go to next stage,
those will have to update.
But it's certainly a lot of interaction,
a lot more team focused in a sense.
Maybe I'll pass the ball up to Teresa because I could
probably keep going here for another 10 minutes about this.
Riffing off the first thing,
you said about it not being monolithic industry versus academia.
Part of that is that there are many partnerships and programs that
foster collaboration between academic groups and industry.
That can take many forms of either sharing technology or doing like a postdoc,
visiting at research lab in the industry part.
There's a lot of activity going on there,
and a lot of collaborations are now being encouraged by the government and new programs.
One thing that I really appreciate about working in industry
over academic labs that I have been in is that,
you get to participate in
really efficient technological developments in a larger team where there's
career experts in their specialized roles that can
be really relied upon to perform their function at the highest level.
Like we have a hardware team that has been doing hardware development for decades,
and gone through many technological innovations over that time,
and they know how to like carry things forward.
We have a fabrication team that's also very high in expertise.
The software team.
They're all really good, and it's not like that in academia where by design,
there's a lot of education going on and there's a constant export of talent.
That's where you go and learn everything, and there are many.
That's where all the smartest people in the world I write is that the universities.
But then once a person becomes an expert in something,
they leave or go and learn something else.
I guess what I appreciated about the industrial environment is
that expert stay doing what their expert at.
Then by constructing the teams efficiently,
we're able to work together to build something that's much
bigger than you can generally achieve in a research group.
Now that's a really good point.
I think we we've saw that in the different panels that we had over the last year.
Talking about like if you're joining an academy group as a PI,
or if you're turning in a startup, or industry,
you have really different roles because the goal ought not the same.
I think academia has more of an educational purpose to train people.
Startups will try to disrupt and find new ways,
and industry has more of a product and
like particularly in mind to have some something and,
so I think that's something that you want to consider also
for your research in carriers like what's the angle?
What would you like to do in your life?
Do you want to teach students?
Do you want to create serve?
Do you want to create a product that could be used
widely by the total population of by system?
That's something to also keep in mind.
Since you have so many options on that,
can you talk a little bit about what's your
day-to-day like is in industry for people who have no idea?
Because I think the big idea
comes from the fact that we have one word to decry all of that,
but there's so many different jobs,
and so what do you do?
Like if you if you have a typical jobs?
I can maybe jump in here and build off of what Teresa said,
and I'll see,
like teaching and all these different things like initially I
think before joining the industry,
research side of it, I thought there was less of that,
but actually we have a giant team focused on education.
One thing I never anticipated, is,
I've taught it to summer schools now on like
introduction to quantum hardware and introduction to quantum noise,
personally had like 4,000 something students.
Second one had like 5,000 plus students global, worldwide.
I think one thing I've found is that there's
just a pretty big world and usually if you really want to be happy,
you have to align your interests with the larger interests.
Oftentimes if you're doing a degree in something like quantum,
you're usually pretty smart, resourceful person,
so you can find those potentials.
That's why a typical day for me at least has evolved a lot.
Initially, I've had days where it was just very focused on work.
Nowadays it's a lot of more mission building and team-building as well.
Trying to scale as well.
I think the interpersonal becomes a lot more of your time as well.
I think typically in industry because you're really working in
teams and take your mission to greater things.
It becomes more of a mission tuba.
I've had sprints where it's been just software development,
and sprints where it's been a lot of reading papers or physics.
At least in my case, it's been quite colorful,
and it keeps evolving and shifting.
It's been a lot more dynamic in that sense,
so not sure if that's helpful,
but hopefully it helps paint a picture.
I mean, everything is very helpful because what we're trying to do is like trying to
see like how people who have similar backgrounds experienced their new role in history?
I think it's very helpful capability know
exactly what it is because somebody who doesn't like to teach,
end up being in your position might be disappointed that
he was like they were finding something slightly different.
It's very nice.
Go on.
Keep going, I will show you.
I guess the thought I had here on one piece of advice,
I think when I was interviewing and applying was,
there's no perfect position for you.
You ideally, you define your own position
and that's the only time you're really going to have that position,
and I've had the chance to keep reshaping,
and so I think maybe that's one thing to
keep in mind is like you have an agency in this,
it's not like you have to fit in a fixed bucket and fit the mold.
Like you have agency, you have flexibility. I'll leave it at that.
That's something that we'll talk about in a few moments later.
We're going to let Teresa talk about experience in a child,
and then we'll talk about how you can craft
your your job to really match what your interests are.
I think that's a really excellent point that you're emphasizing
Zlatko that you have agency to craft your own experience.
That's especially true after you like done your service of a year,
maybe at the company to like show that you're smart and can work with people.
Then like you can move
into what you figure out is your ideal role as you figure that out,
or if you want to try out new things within the same company.
Thankfully, like you said, Zlatko,
I've been able to keep my experience dynamic and try out some different things,
and day-to-day is not always the same.
When I first started the company,
I was mostly doing experimental measurements,
measuring the quantum devices.
I would go in and do electrical test on devices,
sit down at a dilution refrigerator,
or remote into a computer,
whereas accessing a device that's cool down in a refrigerator,
and do electrical test on it.
One difference between my experience here
and graduate school is that we have a lot more meetings,
because we have this specialized teams,
and spend more time getting together
to directly provide feedback between the different teams.
As part of the measurement team,
I was reporting the results of measurements back to fabrication team,
and also interfacing a lot with
a theory and modeling teams that we could validate their models.
That's been fun and as my experience has evolved,
I am now more interested in software.
I think that's the interesting thing about industry is that you can find,
especially if you join big groups or big companies,
you have different nodes and then you can pick and involve in
the same company in a way that will not be necessarily possible in Academia,
I think, because you cannot change your group goals like every given on then.
I think now we can jump into more of the nitty-gritty of like,
how did you land that job?
How did you prepare for the job search?
Why were you interested in?
Then also, what are the advice that you can give to people who are seeking job in
industry or how can they prepare to work on that?
Anybody wants to start?
Great. Oh, I can read that off if you want because
I started on the other side and now I'm more on the hiring side.
Yeah, I have two job postings I have actually.
One is on casket metal more software developer physicist focus.
The other one is really a more researcher level focus.
Those are two different roles.
For the different roles that you're applying for,
you're going to have different processes.
Exactly. I think the first thing
you can always start with to prepare is just
yourself in your own background and material usually.
If you're in science or a researcher,
you'll get asked to tell people about your research, your work.
You want to make sure that that's fresh in your mind, you're competent about it.
Oftentimes you'll give a talk or a presentation.
I had to give a talk and a presentation.
I had probably given that talk and presentation like 18,
19 times before giving it in many other rounds of interviews.
I went maybe extra. I don't think you need to do it 20 times,
but you can really prepare that and have a sensitive questions ready.
I think the other thing folks look for a lot isn't just a technical competence.
That's like, let's get you in the door, but that's the bar.
Is this a person that we can get along with?
Is this a person that seems like they actually want this?
Are they playing for the right reasons? Are they motivated?
Are they eager about this?
Because you can have the right skills,
but if you don't have the affinity for the mission,
you're going to end up leaving or you're going to not
just enjoy the job and not do a great job.
Affinity is another key thing,
like demonstrating that in some way.
Then as you get to more software or more of the different more desirable positions,
especially like in the new climate,
you're often going to have a coding interview,
a behavioral interview,
and a technical interview.
Then if you pass those you talk to more team members,
more for culture fit and how can we get along because we only need to play together.
The coding interview, there's many books and coding interviews
or if you've gone for a software position, those really matter.
You want to know whatever language it is,
Python you might, there's like thousands of
resources online for coding interviews that will walk you through the basics.
If you're a physicist, sometimes those coding interviews are more like okay,
can you be proficient enough to do your job,
but that's not weight is heavily.
You might have a physicist interview where you get asked, what's an Ising model?
What are spin interactions?
How do you measure T1 or T2 depending on if you go into measurement team?
Oftentimes you want to understand because the job postings can be quite big.
You want to understand from the hiring manager of the head,
like what's really the general focus of this role?
Then sometimes you have behavioral interviews,
so you can look those up.
Depends on different companies do it differently.
There's no place that has the exact same process.
But really the idea there is just to make sure that,
you have a good mindset right.
Maybe I'll leave it off to Teresa to add on more here.
Sure. I like what you said.
I would add to that.
Don't try to squeeze yourself into a box that you think
the ideal candidate for a given position is describing.
Oftentimes, the job requisitions are written
in a way that I think you said opaque psycho.
Adds are like that too.
I'm not sure why they pass through some HR filter before they go out there.
Anyway, like generally what places are more looking
for is what kind of a scientist are you?
Do you have the affinity
for doing something that is matching with the mission of the organization?
Are you good cultural fit?
Yeah, I guess,
don't try to squeeze yourself into a box because you don't know what that box looks like.
The company wants to hire a good scientist.
Once you're at the company,
you generally will have some freedom to be you at your best.
I guess one more thing about giving a research presentation.
It's like, Zlatco describes when you go to do a presentation.
It's just like doing interview talk for a postdoc or professorship candidacy.
Usually you talk about some prior research project,
come into basically recycle your thesis defense presentation.
But my piece of advice is that you need
to communicate something technical and prove that you could do that.
But you also have the opportunity to share more about yourself.
What kind of a scientist are you?
What challenges have you encountered and had to overcome?
How do you work with and appreciate other people?
If you can add little anecdotes to that end in there.
More than just conveying physics information.
We really look for that.
Yeah. I can maybe add to that also because people look for cultural phenols.
What does that even mean? What are they actually talking about?
I think a lot of times that's the thing where it's not like you have to exceed,
its not like you need an A plus, you just need a pass.
Is this somebody that I could see myself getting along with?
It's the thing that's more making sure there's
no red flags like this isn't just going to derail the mission.
I think just don't over stress about that as well.
Then I think like Teresa said,
yeah make sure that you generate yourself.
One thing that I do notice folks,
sometimes an interview processes though
what oftentimes will happen is they'll get stressed or freaked out,
but they don't know the answer to something that we can't quite remember it.
The point of these interviews isn't for you to get it right.
Most of the companies,
they are just testing for the boundaries of your knowledge and just getting a sense.
Actually as the hiring managers or the interviewers
job oftentimes is to just keep asking questions until you can't answer anymore.
They just want to see where that boundary is and if part of it is shallow,
that's okay because you've probably got another part
that's deep and you can help steer the conversation too,
it's not always clear to the hiring person exactly who they're dealing with.
They just have three minutes right before this talk
between the other talk to look at your CV.
You can help guide them as well.
These are things I'm strong at,
these are things I love to do.
The two of you can work together on that.
Have energy, have excitement.
Don't let that stress really make you tense.
Melanie, you're our expert on that field.
Can you give us some advice on quantum like what to do
because we had excellent advice from Zlatko on practice?
How can students right now who are looking for jobs
can put all the chance on their sides to land a position?
I think that's an excellent question,
Florian and I have to say everyone on the call today is taking a great first step.
They are hearing from people who are in industry and they're hearing
about what people in the industry are looking for.
Zlatko has some postings coming open
and he'll be hiring soon and so it's good to hear from hiring managers.
It's good to hear from Teresa about her experience on
the job and what her employer looks for and does.
You can go through this exercise
on your own whether you're an undergraduate or graduate student,
post-doc, or someone who's on the job market now through networking.
I think networking is critical to anyone who is interested in this field.
Because the more you can connect with scientists who are doing the work now,
the more you'll hear about how to prepare.
How do you prepare to give a presentation?
How do you prepare for a behavioral interview?
What does that even mean?
What kinds of questions might you hear?
Teresa mentioned cultural fit. What does that mean?
How will you ever know whether you would match a particular company's culture?
That is all through talking with people who are actively in the field now.
You can do that through LinkedIn,
you can do that through scientific societies, professional associations.
You can do that in many different ways.
I know that Yale actually has a very robust alumni database.
You can get in touch with people who are working in quantum science now
through possibly your institutions' alumni office or the Career Center.
There are many different ways that you can start to get into the field,
make contacts in the field even before applying for jobs.
You can be online and you can be looking at job postings and you can be applying.
Oh, that's great, Zlatko.
That's excellent.
Zlatko mentioned at my chat that he's on the Yale alumni database.
It's important and someone on the call who has already connected with me on LinkedIn,
you connect with any of us then you'll be
connected or be able to see all of our connections.
It's important for you to start building out your web of
contacts because that will help you.
Once you do see a posting that is interesting to you in your field,
you can start to apply online.
There's nothing wrong with applying online first,
there's no harm in it it's free but the chances that you'll be called back
are so much more likely if you have any connection at all with any person,
any scientist, anyone who is connected to
that organization so networking is the key I think.
Thank you. Then here you're mentioning all the resources.
We know fairly well the carrier sources at St. Joseph, at Yale,
and at the University of Arizona because we're working with them but
I'm sure for anybody who is affiliated with
any university or any school you should be able to find similar resources in your center.
We have a couple of question on the chat from the audience.
We're talking about how to prepare for interview but also,
what are the skills that are currently hard to find when
people are trying to hire new quantum employees.
What are the skill that add value for employers?
I think it would depend on the type of company.
But do you have a sense is there a gap in
the market and then people should go into certain avenue,
what I consider as second path because that's
something that you see in your industry was,
Oh, we wish you could have that type of skills.
What could be something that current students should look into?
Teresa, you want to swap around and you go first this time?
I can go first too if you want.
Well, I don't have a sense of the whole quantum workforce market.
Do you want to talk,
for example, I'm going to put in the presentation.
I see that on your websites,
on the quantum website section of HRL,
you have a lot of job posting.
The current year there was
29 posts and so when you see this thing it's mostly people with
strong background in science so I think one of
the thing you need to do is quantum is pretty rough.
It's a pretty difficult topic and so having strong solid knowledge in physics,
same or engineering is something that will be
helpful and will also help you to transition to other jobs.
Zlatko if you have more go right ahead.
I can jump in. There's an entire field of
people working on identifying the gaps in the workforce and workforce development.
Workforce development in and of itself it's like
a whole big part of IBM and big industry.
There was a LPS collaboratory workshop.
I gave a little speech [inaudible] well
all over these other people where they're too from
industry and government and all the sectors.
They're identifying the gaps because there's so many different positions.
I think they're going to have an official big report and it's going to
have a very well digested version.
Just quantum, just quantum skills in general.
There's like 50 posts between HRL and IBM now.
That's a lot of posts. How many PhD students
get produced per lab per year? Not a lot, right?
Just quantum basic 101 like understanding quantum physics,
quantum algorithms to some degree already is just a huge gap.
That's changing. Especially even at the masters level and
the undergrad level those jobs didn't
exist before but now there's a lot of demand for those jobs.
Teresa said not every single person needs a PhD to do
their job the PhD gives you a lot of breadth in that but this is great to add on.
I think the other skill that I think would help a lot is really just software.
Especially in quantum software is a huge part of everything we do.
The way we run experiments,
the way you go into the lab,
almost everything is software controlled.
Anything higher level anytime you want to work with whether
it's client or researchers or you want to do anything it's usually through software.
That was a skill that half of our group was really into and
the other half was totally against basically at the time in my degree.
Having better developer software skills even if that's
not your primary role it's just such an essential tool
and I see it in a lot of candidates
just it's not to the level that it would really benefit them.
Presentation skills are always very important
as well because you end up having to present a lot.
But I think just within quantum,
just understanding a little bit about quantum computing,
quantum basics, fundamentals,
some quantum algorithms at the basic level,
this is all super helpful.
I actually have a question. You've all been
talking about software and so we have question from the chat.
What is the difference between applying to be a software engineer in
a big tech company which I think is pretty thinking about, oh,
how to develop Twitter or Facebook,
these software needs and the difference between being
an actual software for quantum systems?
Is there a difference?
How do you get this because you can start
coding on Python for your mini app or something like this.
But how do you start coding on a quantum system?
How do you train yourself for that?
I can go first [inaudible]
I guess something comes to my mind that there is, of course,
a wide variety of software tasks associated with
the field of quantum information and some of those are more theoretical,
but on the experimental side,
the stress on the software
is more related to the interface between the software and the hardware.
Because our hardware of the quantum system is in many implementations,
inaccessible by being at the level of dilution refrigerator.
Doing the quantum software is really doing
a special classical software to control whatever control electronics there are.
Whether it's control electronics at the top
of the fridge or advanced control electronics.
Some companies are doing cryogenic controllers
and software needs to be written to control,
it's very specialized hardware.
That is a unique skill that I wouldn't say,
is shared with the app development and stuff. It's very much new.
Awesome. Yeah and I would add to that.
There's software that's lower down the stack as you might say,
like closer to the hardware.
Usually that requires a lot more domain knowledge,
a lot more expertise about [inaudible] to have worked in a lab.
Not necessarily, but usually,
to actually understand the cubits, what's the [inaudible] rotation?
How does it work? What's pulse shaping pulses?
If you want more,
what I will colloquially call hardcore quantum software developer position,
you really need to be pretty good at that.
Sometimes, there's a lot of work on compilers.
In that case, you might need compiler knowledge background
as well or you can pick it up on the Java.
I have a good friend who's absolutely excellent at it. He just pick that up.
But I think overall there's just nothing more of an emphasis on quantum.
It's probably a little different in that, I think,
if you're going for a traditional software role,
you're probably going to get a lot more questions about
software architecture and software design.
You're going to have a software design principle part of your coding interview like
different model-view-controller framework or you might get asked questions like that.
Whereas here I think it's more like a mix between
the quantum flavor and the like do you have the right abstractions?
Can you build abstractions correctly place for that?
Do you just have the operating skills?
Well for our part of industry,
can you work in an open source environment or
heavy down contributions to an open source repo.
Do you understand the open source ecosystem?
That's one big part of inch because many of these industries,
IBM in particular now it's very open source-based.
That has a slightly different flavor and
obviously project management and so forth like GitHub and all that as well.
Thank you. We have another question from the chats.
Are there any opportunity available for
undergrads to have hands-on experience on quantum hardware?
Is their internship possible and where do you find,
and I think that could also be a question for millennia,
where do you find the resources?
Is there job posting board somewhere that
recognize that has all these opportunities and what could be.
I know these days there is a ton of hackathon happening all over the world.
While it's not hands-on on hardware,
you will still code onto actual hardware through the Cloud system.
But do you have any mention of what students can do and is
there clubs or stuff in
the opportunities for internships in companies and where do you find this?
I'm so glad you mentioned that Florian hackathons
because you know the ability to code and having
some concrete evidence for
any employer of your skills is so powerful, it's so meaningful.
I think that the more that students can engage in that activity, the better.
In terms of hosting for internships,
I would think carefully about where you'd like to be geographically
and then look at local quantum employers.
People who might have internships available and go to their websites directly,
not as big a fan as big broad job boards
as I'm for particular places like IBM or HRO having their own posts.
That's more, I would be more targeted in terms of where you'd like to be
geographically and then target some quantum employers.
Yeah, and I can probably also add to that
because quantum hardware design is, well, my world.
I would say, look at what projects are out there and try to get involved,
probably through open source.
That will often lead you to hackathons or
Slack channels where you're going to meet and discuss and people post things.
For instance, we have several internships
for kids get metal which suffer from quantum hardware design.
You get to work with that.
We designed a five cubic device,
is going to the University of Tokyo with kids get metal.
Some folks from Chalmers are using it as well.
There's a summer school actually,
I think it's quantum BC in Canada and CNC microsystems.
They organized summer school with kids get metal where you get
to design your quantum hardware then actually gets fabricated and then you measure it.
These opportunities actually exist.
Some of them are more regional,
some of them are more international.
There is global summer schools on that but if you contribute or hang out,
first of all, if you hang out in a community like that,
like a Slack channel, that's great.
But if you're active and you contribute to accomplish something like that,
people who are working on that, will notice you immediately.
They're going to know your name.
If you asked internships, people will reach out and actively help you.
I think that's always a great way, like Melanie said,
don't just go to jobs.com and type in this because you're going
to spend a lot of effort and your result might just is going to be a lot harder that way.
All these advise are valid for people who are international.
We are all based in the US.
But there's, I think since the pandemic,
a lot of companies,
a lot of university have moved towards online platforms.
The hackathon that you could take part was locally people had to be in the same room.
Now they're available to any countries in the world.
It's going to be a challenge for the time zone sometimes.
But I think some big company are
hosting different hackathon for different part of the world.
One thing that you get out of this is that you also build your network.
The reason why these big companies and
university are hosting this hackathon is really to get talents.
Finding a job is not really just a home for you as a candidate.
The company needs to fill these places,
it needs to work.
You are not fighting against industry to get your job,
it's mostly a collaboration and say if you can work with your network and
with the people who are hosting the hackathon who are judging,
we see that you've proved that you could do some amazing coding or
some amazing way of processing a different signal in a different way.
That's something that they might keep in mind and then they might post,
they might follow up and send you job postings and say like,
hey, there is something that you might be interested in.
I think the geography while it's challenging,
is not really a big barrier.
There's a shortage of quantum worker.
No matter where you are in the world,
I think if you have the talents,
you will find a way to bring you to where you need to be. That's also something.
We had a lot of questions in the chat box.
International students agree on this thing.
We have a few more question.
That's an interesting question because it goes
between the few panels that we had in the past
on do you know of any former co-worker who have branched out from industry to startups?
Is there a lot of lateral motion between these two different system?
Can you go from industry to startups and then come back?
Do you have any experience for that?
I've you seen any people who have done that?
Yes, I've seen people go both directions.
I think it's just part of this fairly small but growing world of quantum in industry.
I have friends who have gone both directions.
Cool thing.
We are almost at the end of the panel.
What I propose is that,
I'll give you the second map.
We're going to talk about one last topic.
What would be your advice,
general advice and final remarks for this thing?
But before we do that, Matthews,
I see that you have your hand raised.
Feel free to answer.
I guess my question is,
from the perspective of a graduate student,
a second year graduate student,
who is actually considering to go for Academia.
Maybe it's a more personal question.
What was the point that made you decide to go to industry?
Because at some point, I guess,
every graduate student needs to make that decision.
How did it happen for you?
I can take this one first.
For me it was like way after I got my job offer, actually,
I only applied to industry as a exploratory site option,
that was primarily we're looking at doing postdocs,
and more traditional path if you want,
so it's a bit of a surprise actually playing myself and giving
a career panel on paperwork and joining the workforce and industry.
First of all, I think my advice would be from what I have seen,
there's about 2 percent correlation between what a second-year grad student and what to
sixth-year student and coming out of their PhD is
thinking in terms of academia versus industry.
Honestly, I just wouldn't worry about that very much
because almost every single person I talk to, they were like, "Oh,
I'm 100 percent going to industry,
I'm 100 percent going to academia or I could do mistakes, academia is awesome. "
By the time you're in your 4th to 6th year,
you're a totally different person like that stuff is like,
so whatever you thinking now,
just for you that it's cool,
it's great you're thinking about it,
I'm appreciative of that, but honestly,
just focus right now on developing yourself to the best you can be in this environment,
because if you're looking over there,
but you're having to move in this direction, you're going to trip up.
An industry is not going to go as well as you want,
and academia isn't, I will say just develop yourself.
At the same time go to career panels, go to conferences,
build that network that Melanie mentioned,
talk to people in both sides and get a good environment,
but you do not have to make the decision right now.
You do not have to choose right now,
and whatever you choose right now it's your ultimate destiny will work out either way,
so that would be my first advice.
I think, how did I choose?
Like I said, I ended up choosing very late in the process,
and I decided that it's a very unique time in quantum,
and that's the other thing you cannot predict.
When I was in my second year of teaching,
there was no quantum industry,
maybe IBM was the only place or maybe there's two places or
three places in the world that had quantum teams and industry, it didn't even exist.
Even in 2015,
it was pretty late in my PhD,
I thought I didn't really think industry was a thing in quantum,
and so the landscape will change and you do have to adjust with that blueprint as well.
I think at that time it seemed like this is
a once in a blue moon potential opportunity with somebody with quantum.
If there's ever a time to be more adventurous and do an experiment with
my own career and my own life and see how that goes into more that takes me,
this is the time and as said go on a bold,
faith and leap and explore this other pursued,
knowing that it may be a little more difficult to transition back
to academia proper if I wanted to but that's always an option,
these decisions are in final.
As we have seen, people going from industry to startup industry to academia,
academia to startup academia,
it's the goal of these pathways still are possible.
Then one thing that I want to add also is
that there's a ton of opportunities you're not even aware of,
and so if you really focus on one aspect of thinking like, "oh,
I want to work on that field," you might miss something that's very interesting.
For example, I worked in higher education,
like I'm doing more program development for economy students and researchers,
and it's something that I was not ready.
Like I was following the path of I have a PhD,
I wanted to become a faculty member,
and then one day there was this opportunity was like, oh,
that sounds like an actual job that I would like,
and so I think that's also something to keep in mind is that this panel are
divided in section because we need to find a way to put them in boxes,
but it's more like a continuum.
I'm going to make this corny joke about quantum system,
it's not on and off,
but it's all of the above,
everything is mixed together and you have all these opportunities that come your way.
Yes, so thank you so much for taking the time of being on that panel,
maybe we can do one that's round,
and then if you have last piece of advice for all of attendees,
that will be wonderful.
In the same times,
I will put on the slides,
if I can find my study ends, here we go.
On the slides, the job posting of your two companies so people can have a look.
Maybe let's start with you, Teresa,
if you want to have the last word,
that could also be like, good luck.
Industry jobs in quantum fields are definitely here,
I think they're pretty attractive, great option.
For me, my appetite was what for
doing industrial R&D probably
before I started graduate school because I worked in R&D lab,
that was actually in chemistry,
so I knew that I wanted to work in that environment before starting my PhD.
Now that I've been doing so at a single company for
five years and seen remarkable progress in our technology during my time here,
I find that exciting.
If you're interested in learning more about quantum dot physics,
I encourage you to find our papers and videos
or if some videos ever conference presentations on
our website and we're hiring people from a variety of backgrounds. Check out our website.
Thank you very much.
You have the slide on your screen,
let's go do you want to say a few more words.
Awesome. A tourist said it perfectly,
really awesome, so what other words do I have?
I think one, don't stress out honesty.
You are like a golden age,
maybe pause and just take a moment of gratitude for how awesome of a place you are.
If you're in this quantum seminar,
you are in a golden age,
you're really having a great time.
There's so many opportunities and options,
like Florian and Teresa said,
I've been in industry for a few years now and I keep
learning about new roles that I didn't even know existed even within my own company,
there's just so many different varieties and flavors opportunities.
I think with that re-echo what I said is like,
you can start here,
but again, at the day,
I think your greatest potential for joy and happiness will be if you can
help define your own roll down the line within that as well as much possible.
Just reach out to folks like Teresa and
me or your friends and just to hear their stories,
that will really give you a great map of the landscape,
and I'm sure you'll do great.
Thank you, Zlatko.
I need you to have a few last bit of advice for attendees.
Florian, just following your passion,
I think everyone has talked about that on the call today.
Florian, I'm so glad that you said more information about
your job because there are so many opportunities
out there for students interested in being around one and talking about it,
writing about it, studying it,
contributing to the fields,
there are so many opportunities right now.
It's like Zlatko said this is a golden age,
such an exciting time to be in quantum,
so I think I would really think about what you like to do most and really perceive that,
so thank you so much for having me.
Of course, it's my pleasure.
Then while we conclude,
this is the list of all the panels that we had in the past,
so we tried to cover everything.
Had to prepare and choose courses for college,
had to prepare for grad school,
had to prepare for faculty, and we also had one for startups,
and so all of this video will be available on replay on the Yale YouTube channels,
so thank you very much and I'm putting the link in the chat also if you want.
Thank you very much for your time,
thank you all for sharing your experiences
and helping us understand what it's like to work in industry,
and thank you all for attending this seminar.
I hope you have a wonderful evening and a great began.
Thank you all.